l'institut mérieux à 100 ans aujourd'hui
5000 personnes se sont rassemblées à
lyon pour célébrer l'anniversaire de cet
institut qui est passé en un siècle du
petit laboratoire artisanat lyonnais un
des premier groupe mondial du vaccin et
de la médecine vétérinaire
c'est l'histoire de cette réussite que
nous retrace philippe lemaire et patrice
didier demain le groupe pasteur mérieux
chrono et fabriquera le vaccin contre le
sida dans ses laboratoires américains en
mars il estoit dans la banlieue de lyon
en multiplie les combinaisons génétiques
pour produire non plus les vaccins
partir de cultures de cellules animales
mais à partir de génie génétique bientôt
n'immunisent en même temps l'enfant
contre la diphtérie la polio la
coqueluche l'hépatite b ou encore la
ménagerie se sont toutes les voies
nouvelles qui explore les chercheurs
d'un groupe devenu en sentant numéro un
mondial du vaccin
aujourd'hui ce que l'on pense aussi
c'est développer des vaccins contre des
maladies telles que l'ulcère gastrique
telles que les cancers avec des concepts
nouveaux qui du fait de des réponses
particulières du système immunitaire
pourrait permettre de mettre au point
des vaccins que l'on qualifie presse
aujourd'hui le thérapeutique
il ya comme cela des entreprises
industrielles qui ont le succès inscrits
dans leurs gènes en un siècle d'histoire
de l'institut mérieux est ponctué de ses
intuitions capable de propulser un
groupe où sommet elle est étroitement
associée aux rêves de ces hommes qui ont
fondé la dynastie et qui quelque part
ont toujours su modeler la réalité à la
dimension de leur rêve en 1897 donc il
ya d'abord marcel mérieux chimiste de
formation ancien passe rien il fonde
l'institut bactériologique de lyon qui
deviendra l'institut biologique meirieu
surtout marcel mérieux sera le premier à
donner une dimension industrielle à la
production de vaccins que ce soit pour
protéger les hommes
avant de s'orienter vers la médecine
vétérinaire
il y aura ensuite charles mérieux le
visionnaire le poète celui qui réussit
le mariage contre nature de l'industrie
est de l'humanitaire son plus beau
souvenir d'homme c'est d'avoir réussi à
terrasser en 1975 l'épidémie de
méningite qui allait ravager le brésil
après 11 ans s'envolait de 10 ans de
recherche
on a passé 100 millions de brésiliens le
ministre dany boon et les villages et
c'était un miracle jamais eu autant on
fera des choses comme ça
les américaines qui vous savez du coin
de l'oeil ils me l'ont dit après mais
c'est faux je vous avais fait parce que
les 4000 morts du début en france mais
ont coûté plus cher et samuel vacciner
est large et a pris comme ça l'économie
de la santé et de l'action humanitaire
alors génie b celui rats qui sera pas de
trappe en il faut petit définitif en
france on n'en a pas conscience mais au
brésil le nom de mérieux est devenu une
sorte de mythe
cette halle à mairieux qui succédant à
son père sera l'artisan du rapprochement
avec rhône poulenc avant que le géant de
la chimie ne contrôlent la totalité du
capital de l'institut avec rhône poulenc
s'ouvrait la voie royale pour que le
groupe devienne numéro un mondial de la
médecine vétérinaire avec rhône meirieu
et du vaccin avec pasteur mérieux côte
mais ce n'est déjà plus tout à fait
l'histoire de la dynastie meirieu
où